c'était donc miel en banlieue on attend
vos réactions bien sûr sur le hashtag
docu débat ce documentaire a été réalisé
par vous florent collodion
coréalisé même avec adrien urbain merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés dominic
sena bonjour vous êtes apiculteurs
administrateur de l'union nationale de
l'apiculture française
près de vous axel des courtiers vous
êtes écotoxicologue directeur
scientifique et technique de liszt ap
institut de l'abeille bienvenus en face
de vous laurence abeilles bonjour vous
êtes député europe ecologie les verts du
val de marne présidente du groupe
d'études de l'assemblée nationale sur la
biodiversité et enfin bruno parmentier
bienvenus vous êtes ingénieur économiste
conférencier et ancien directeur de
l'école supérieure d'agriculture
d'angers bienvenue à tous alors on parle
beaucoup des abeilles en ce moment leur
survie est devenue une grande cause en
france et aux états unis à quel moment
florent vous vous y êtes intéressés ça
date de quand le début de votre enquête
on va dire que ça débute en fait dès
l'enfance j'ai commencé à manger du miel
donc l'attrait pour les abeilles ça a
commencé tout petit mais plus
particulièrement sa course et sur un
ancien documentaire qui s'appelle de la
terre à l'assiette en arménie et c'était
donc pour filmer des potagers comment
les personnes arrivaient à être
autosubsistance avec leur potager et
c'était en zone très rurale l'arménie
est très peu urbaine à part la capitale
et en revenant en 2013 j'ai rencontré
enfin adrien était un ami mais j'ai
rencontré son père qui venait
d'installer des ruches dans son pavillon
dans le val d'oise donc à eaubonne
michel urbain et donc adrien urbain -
invités à participer à une récolte et là
quelle surprise de trouver donc dans une
zone urbaine un petit pavillon certes
avec un jardin peut-être 250 mètres
carrés mais surtout une ruche ont placé
à deux mètres cinquante de la porte
d'entrée donc on passait directement les
cadres directement par la fenêtre on se
retrouvait dans le salon et les amène à
suivre le miel arrivée dans la maison et
là ça a été une prise de conscience
qu'on peut vivre uniquement en harmonie
avec la bei près de chez soi en zone
urbaine alors effectivement c'est ce
qu'on découvre dans votre dans votre
documentaire que les abeilles
aujourd'hui yves mieux en ville qu'à la
campagne c'est quand même un comble
aujourd'hui c'est ça que vous vouliez
montré en fait c'est cette question là
que ça vous a posé puisque vous savez
qu'en fait elle elle le fuyait quelque
part les campagnes je pense pas qu'il
faut voir le problème comme ça nous on
l'a plutôt traitée sur le fait qu'ils
avaient 15 % mortalité donc qu'elle
meure - o ville qu'à la campagne dont
certaines campagnes tout est à
relativiser donc c'est pas dire qu'elles
vivent mieux mais plutôt essayer de
comprendre où elles vivent quels sont
les apiculteurs comment on peut
pratiquer une apiculture aux zones
urbaines sont mettre en danger les gens
tout aussi en essayant de préserver la
bei et en essayant de développer sa
présence le mieux possible plus qu'elles
soient en harmonie en zone urbaine
c'est à dire que on a fait un peu
volontairement le mot banlieue parce que
c'est souvent en fait rempli de préjugés
on entende banlieue on pense tout de
suite à des situations difficiles
défavorisés nous qui sommes nés dans le
val d'oise soit je suis né à colombes
dans le 92 on a eu une autre vision de
cette banlieue avec beaucoup de forêts
avec beaucoup de jardins on avait
novellon se promenait et on a voulu
montrer en fait ce visage de la banlieue
qui est
immédiat vous vous doutiez il ya deux
ans que ce sujet des abeilles serait
aussi important est omniprésent dans le
débat public
oui j'espérais en tout cas et si on a
fait une film c'était pour pour amener
pour participer parce que des gens comme
l'unaf l'union nationale de l'apiculture
française ont déjà commencé ce combat
plus d'une dizaine d'années il ya vingt
ans peut-être déjà il essaye de faire en
sorte que que ça soit le plus médiatique
possible mais aujourd'hui je pensais pas
voir une telle popularité de la bei en
fait dès qu'on a parlé nous de notre
film les mairies nous ont ouvert les
bras les entreprises qu installer des
ruches nous ont ouvert les bras on était
haut commissariat à l'énergie atomique
ont a été donc au jardin du luxembourg
des lieux dans lesquels avec un autre
sujet on nous aurait pas forcément donné
les autorisations tout de suite vos
réactions à ce documentaire à dominique
senard cet apiculteur je vous donne la
parole en premier
je rejoins ce qui vient d'être dit c'est
la belle sait reste quelque chose de
curieux de mystérieux et
d'attrayant quand je dis mystérieux tout
le monde sait ce que c'est qu'une fleur
ou à peu près tout le monde sait ce que
c'est qu'un pot de miel ou à peu près
mais la relation qui peut y avoir entre
la fleur l'insecte la ruche en passant
par l'alimentation humaine et le pot de
miel fina qui lui en plus c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau c'est vraiment
quelque chose de fabuleux et je pense
que c'est un peu à condition qu'on soit
piqué par le virus exprimons à
l'expression
c'est un peu ça qui fait qui rend
l'enfant qui donne l'envi
qui plus est aujourd'hui on est
confronté donc comme ce que vient de
dire
les mortalités nous inquiète beaucoup
les difficultés de l'apiculture la
complexité les apiculteurs aujourd'hui
des situations auxquelles on ne s'attend
pas
des chamboulements complet au niveau de
la ruche au niveau de l'insecte on a du
mal à comprendre par moment ce qui se
passe et je pense que c'est aujourd'hui
un vrai sujet après sujets de société il
faut aussi penchés sérieusement et c'est
ce qui donne la trait à l'activité de
cette société et économique au silence
avec wind 1 c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet économique parce que l'agriculture
c'est ce qui nourrit la planète et sans
pollinisateurs on ne se nourrira plus
donc c'est un peu la fin de l'humanité
qui est annoncé avec la disparition des
abeilles jouent cette inquiétude qui
grandit quand même dans la dans la
population et qui est de plus en plus
partagée même si en corse est encore
relativement timide par parler politique
mais c'est vrai que depuis depuis deux
trois ans on essaie d'avoir des actions
fortes au niveau du sénat de l'assemblée
nationale pour faire comprendre qu on
vit dans des écosystèmes et que quand un
morceau de l'éco système ne fonctionne
plus à ce moment là tout se détruit et
la bei est vraiment l'insecte sans doute
le plus symbolique est aimé de la
population c'est vrai il est animal
sympathique il produit ce miel qui est
doré t bonds et en même temps il permet
il permet de polliniser tous les fruits
et les légumes
voit la mer mais il ya encore sept je
pense cette cette grande timidité fin
pour tout dire même nom mais vis-à-vis
de la part des politiques d'aller vers
la protection des écosystèmes parce que
sans ces écosystèmes
effectivement nous n'existerons plus la
bei évidemment et l'abeille est le
symbole de l' équilibre de la
biodiversité et des écosystèmes et donc
en ville comme on le voit dans le
reportage où effectivement elle se
trouve bien parce qu'il ya un écosystème
qui leur convient plutôt pas mal en
revanche dès qu'on sort et dans les
territoires beaucoup plus ou là de
monoculture des territoires de grandes
cultures à ce moment là on voit bien que
les abeilles sont dans des situations
très très dur axel de continuer
oui c'est vrai qu'on met souvent en
avant l'activité économique les
bénéfices économiques liées à la bei on
a tous en tête ses 53 milliards d'euros
qui sont qui serait produit par la
pollinisation par les abeilles on voit
dans ce reportage que ça va au delà
parce que l'apiculture en fait c'est une
activité de partage aussi voilà c'est un
lien social concret en ville et c'est
d'autant plus un lien social intéressant
qui se fait autour d'un animal social il
ya beaucoup d'analogies dans le
reportage entre l'animal social la
société et puisqu'on voilà ce qu'on
projette sur cet animal que ce soit la
monarchie que ce soit quelqu'un qui dit
l'abeille et et socialement intégré à la
ville donc voilà ça c'est intéressant
maintenant attention on combat avec ce
reportage est avec l'apiculture en ville
une idée fausse qui serait dire les
villes sont des territoires stérile où
il n'ya pas de fleurs c'est faux par
contre attention à l'idée fausse qui
remplacerait la première veut dire
l'urbanisme l'organisation c'est bon
pour les abeilles
ce serait les cas c'est un peu l'école
de ces raccourcis la pointe a menti oui
ce film invite à changer de regard ce
qu'en fait nous on dit il ya la ville
puis la campagne quoi alors bluffant je
pensais que les abeilles moins meurent
moins en ville qu'à la campagne mais
au-delà de ça la nourriture c'est pas
uniquement des choses qui viennent de la
campagne en ville en banlieue il ya
énormément de gens qui ont des jardins
alors pour le moment la crise économique
ne nous fera pas je vous rappelle la
crise économique c'est très simple c'est
quand les banlieusards retire le rosier
pour mettre des pommes de terre mais
ceci dit une fois qu'on a dit ça il ya
on peut faire énormément de légumes
aussi en ville pas seulement du miel et
c'est une des solutions pour mieux
nourrir les grandes villes du monde de
remettre de l'agriculture en ville alors
en ville c'est pas tellement à pailles
paris a pas beaucoup d'espacé
extrêmement serré il n'y a pas de
terrasse mais si on commence à prendre
la banlieue on se perçoit à travers le
film qui est normal mais dans les
grandes villes du tiers-monde n'en
parlons pas et c'est un jeu majeur
finalement l'agriculture urbaine ça va
s'étendre donc ce phénomène affluent
cozian probablement même âge je miserais
beaucoup sur son extension est sûre
alors l'extension va falloir faire
attention faut que les gens ne
m'installes pas une ruche c'est pas si
simple que ça c'est pas uniquement un
loisir c'est vraiment une activité où il
faut faire des bilans très sains
d'ailleurs plusieurs fois par mois donc
faut faire vraiment attention nous sur
le film on s'est un petit peu moins
concentré sur la mortalité des abeilles
parce qu'il ya déjà eu beaucoup de
documentaires qui en parlaient
scientifiquement nous on a vraiment
essayé de savoir ce qu'ils en ville
qu'est-ce qu'elle apportait aux êtres
humains quand ils les élèves et ceux qui
y participent aussi parce qu'un
apiculteur va toujours invité ses
voisins ses amis à participer est ce
qu'on se rend compte c'est que
l'apiculteur ben en fait va changer de
regard sur sa banlieue et va identifier
les fleurs autour de lui que les
abeilles vont aller butiner et vous va
essayer de contribuer à leur
prolifération
essayer certains les incroyables
comestibles vont lancer des petites
graines comme ça à droite à gauche dans
les jardins publics et après il ya
vraiment une démarche de citoyens
constitution d'associations pour dire
effectivement ces territoires
où il ya encore de l'espace on pense aux
terrasses par exemple le toit il ya
quelque chose à faire dessus donc c'est
donc c'est clairement un rapprochement
se fait maintenant entre les villes et
la nature et puis slam engrenage en fait
parce que le rapprochement de la vère la
bei va vers le reste les fleurs etc oui
c'est effectivement cédé des campagnes
de sensibilisation
cclat bay où les abeilles sont à
protéger on le sait il ya il ya des
plans nationaux qui des pouvoirs publics
qui vont dans ce dans ce sens là on a
besoin aussi de cette population qui est
urbaine maintenant on vit dans les
villes cette population soit
sensibilisée à la protection des
abeilles maintenant le reportage montre
en fait trois types d'apiculture un
petit d'apiculture qui est familial
plutôt en dessous des 30 des trente
ruches qui nourrit sa famille avec du
miel ou ses amis voilà ça c'est 90% des
apiculteurs en france après il ya une
apiculture qui est plutôt plus réactive
c'est un second revenu 100 150 ruches et
puis une troisième apiculture qui montre
soit le bout de son nez un c'est en gros
une entreprise qui passent contrat avec
une autre entreprise pour entretenir des
régions ça c'est plutôt une apiculture
qui est très marginal sur le territoire
et on voit des sociétés qui voit la
redorent leur image ou font un outil
management aussi de grâce à la baisse il
manque une apiculture qui l apiculteur
professionnel qui alors là est plutôt
une apiculture clairement rural est qui
et qui produit la plupart du miel en
france ont alors j'ai une question parce
que on comprend dans le documentaire qui
à la belle sauvage l'abeille domestique
j'aimerais comprendre la différence en
fait et qu'est ce qu'une abeille
domestique de mix et là je voudrais
juste rebondir sur ce qui vient d'être
dit ni si je vais vous permettez quand
vous parlez de l'installation de ruches
pour des entreprises qui veulent su
redorer le blason là dessus on partage
complètement ce point de vue à l'unaf
saufs
exception dans le cadre du programme
abeille sentinelle de l'environnement
c'est à dire que la prise de conscience
aujourd'hui elle est claire est ce que
vient de dire florent est exact les
abeilles de ville vont très bien et les
abeilles de campagne vont moins bien
donc d'une façon toute simple le
programme avait senti même fait est là
pour démontrer d'une façon simple on
installe des ruches en ville installe
des ruches en campagne et pourquoi ces
ruches qui sont donc dans les yeux dans
des zones très urbanisées des zones
polluées pourquoi sur six ruches là on a
beaucoup moins de mentalité pourquoi sur
ses ruches là et bien les abeilles
rentrent 30% à 35% plus de miel nous la
démonstration elle est toute simple au
travers de ce programme abeille
sentinelle de l'environnement maintenant
c'est clair aussi tout et l'entreprise
où tous les partenaires qui viennent
nous voir bien s'engage
à respecter une charte c'est à dire que
clermont n'est pas là pour reverdir leur
image c'est sûr maintenant abeilles
domestiques ou abeilles sauvages
pour moi la belle et sauvage ou là mais
pendant des dandys caisse me mettant
dans des ruches mais elle fait ce
qu'elle veut c'est à dire que on a fait
bâtir sur des rayons droit dès lors que
naturellement la baïne bâti un bâti
rarement droit pour des questions de
température les volumes que nous lui
offrons bah c'est pas forcément les bons
volumes jeu chaque évolution où chaque
apiculteurs qui a eu l'idée d'offrir un
meilleur ou une meilleure ruche à la
veille par penser avoir la meilleure
idée en fait naturellement elle a pas
besoin de nous elle fait ce qu'elle veut
c'est un héros c'est une abeilles
sauvages qui s'adapte quelle que soit la
ruche qu'on lui propose c'est ça que
vous êtes en train de dire en fait il
qu'un seul type d'abeilles mais la
veille et très adaptable bon je pense
qu'on peut résumer comme ça mais c'est
aussi pour faciliter le travail de
l'apiculteur est ce qu'en plus la veille
et génère que tu es au delà de leur rôle
dans notre dans notre écosystème les
abeilles on le sait ont un impact
déterminant sur notre santé je voudrais
qu'on réécoute un extrait de votre
documentaire fleuve les abeilles
dans leur miel et les vitamines pro
vitamines oligoéléments celle minéraux
acides aminés vient stase j'en passe
parce que y'a plein et tout ça c'est bon
pour elle c'est bon pour leur corps
c'est bon pour l'heure le re leur
vitalité
c'est très bon pour l'homme aussi pour
ça un mec comme moi 75 verges ma femme
74 par un seul médicament par contre on
utilise beaucoup les produits de la
ruche alors on va en parler un tout au
long du débat les abeilles subissent
aujourd'hui de nombreuses menaces
quelles seraient les conséquences
l'état d'un monde sans abeilles alors ça
va a
été souvent dit y compris on prête à
einstein de cette phrase comme quoi il
n'aurait jamais prononcé mais finalement
c'est une belle légende que qui puisse
l'avoir dit c'est que sansan abeilles à
plus de il y aurait plus d'humanité lieu
de vie sur terre et tout ce qu'on peut
inventer pour essayer de remplacer les
abeilles et d'ailleurs et des tentatives
avec des drones d'un côté ou demandera
la main et cetera bon tout ça notamment
là je pense de manuel part et c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal à chaumont chiffrent en
centaines de milliards au fond les
services que rendent
compte 3 milliards voilà et encore j'ai
moi j'ai dû les j'ai vu des chiffres
assez variés mais qui sont tous
absolument gigantesque donc en fait on
ne peut pas remplacer les abeilles donc
de nous devons protéger les abeilles
impérativement pour nous sauver nous
mêmes ça c'est enfin je pense de ce
point de vue là qu'on doit partir pour
essayer de préserver notre notre
environnement notre humanité pour un
parmentier les abeilles en fait
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont qui les rendent
si indispensable à la pollinisent la
plupart des plantes ont besoin de ce
transport d'une plante à l'autre pour
pouvoir se reproduire et à peu près 80%
des plantes pour situer ses brillantes
donc un monde sans abeilles ya plus que
à peu près les céréales quoi il n'y a
plus que du blé du riz du maïs terminée
il ya plus de free
à plus de légumes il ya plus de pommes
de terre il ya plus de café il ya plus
de cacao il n'y a plus alors c'est ça va
bien au delà des fleurs et reconnaître
nos pots de fleurs un cc c'est très très
impressionnant alors à tel point que par
exemple il ya plus de cerises alors en
chine ils en sont à essayer de grimper
dans les dents les cerisiers au
printemps pour féconder avec un
coton-tige les cerises enfin on imagine
bien que
il ya plus d'abeilles est plus sûr est
ici qu il ya plus de 13 il ya plus
d'abricots il ya plus comme il ya plus
de poires il ya plus donc il ya plus de
tomates enfin on il faut se rendre
compte de cet énorme défi et puisqu'on
est puisqu'on à la veille de l'été noces
nous on va partir en vacances et bien
attendez c'est quand même très
impressionnant c'est beaucoup plus que
les abeilles on peut traverser la france
au mois de juillet sans nettoyer son
pare-brise dorénavant vous rendez compte
que ça veut dire il n'ya plus d'insectes
alors là c'est l'aide notion de dégât
collatéral coin on m'a dit bah il ya des
insectes qui mangent les plantes bon les
plantes c'est pour nous on va les
détruire manque de chance en même temps
on détruit les insectes qui sait comme
les plantes qui leur permettent de vivre
donc à la fin il va falloir rééquilibrer
un petit peu les choses et traversé la
france pour aller en vacances sans
nettoyer son pare-brise voilà ça c'est
un truc que tout le monde peut faire
elle se dit pas quand même c'est
gravissime et s'ils appuient insectes ya
plus d'oiseaux il ya de moins en moins
d'oiseaux particulier au mic sénat la
chaîne alimentaire est impactée c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui on se rend compte
du déficit tout le monde connaît
l'hirondelle peuhmond connaît le mono
bien on se rend compte que au fil des
années eh bien tous ces
ces individus-là disparaissent
clairement j'aimerais aussi avoir sur
notre santé donc là on a parlé de
l'alimentation mais donc si
effectivement on réduit notre
alimentation moitié qui reste plus que
des céréales à terme notre santé ajouter
alors voila voila je fais quand même pas
mal d'animations dans le cadre
associatif et bénévoles vers les enfants
donc la question semble qu'on leur pose
c'est que prenez-vous qui déjeuner le
matin donc ça part dans tous les sens et
jus de fruit et chocolat riz ainsi de
suite ce que vous venez de dire voilà
c'est clairement il reste du thé il
reste du
jury et reste du pain et tout le reste
même le chocolat est tout même le
chocolat même la viande même les
produits laitiers c'est là où ça les
fait voilà alors laquelle la relation
après entre les bovins les ovins les
quatre ans oui mais l'herbe a besoin de
pollinisateurs s'il ya moins de police
auteur il ya moins de nourriture pour
c'est toute la chaîne alimentaire qui
est qui remise en question axel des
courtiers au virage sur ce sujet il faut
bien faire passer le message que là on
parlait d'une nappe une seule espèce
d'abeille qui est la bei élevé par les
apiculteurs qui alors dominé coupat
domestique il ya effectivement on peut
se poser la question parce que des fois
on contrôle pas grand chose mais c'est
une espèce parmi à peu près 1000 espèces
d'abeilles sauvages qui est un monde
assez silencieux qui passe discrètement
qui discrètement dans notre paysage mais
qui sont également essentiels pour la
pollinisation donc quand on regarde
l'abeille mellifère elles représentant
aussi de 1000 espèces d'abeilles
sauvages dans nos paysages et c'est ce
cette diversité là qu'il faut aussi
préserver pour assurer les bénéfices
économiques et puis aussi notre
bien-être parce que cinq fruits et
légumes par jour c'est pas possible sont
les abeilles effectivement et puis la
beauté de nos paysages aussi tout
simplement
alors il ya aussi ce qu'elles fabriquent
les abeilles qui est d'une grande
richesse miel gelée royale propolis
venin quelles sont les vertus de ces
produits qui veut répondre peut l'être
l'aviculteur qui est avec nous le miel
commencer par le miel que tout le monde
connaît donc c'est
vraiment un produit qui est très très
rêche en toutes sortes de choses
notamment tout ce qui concerne
l'alimentation
en sucre clairement on n'a pas besoin de
saccharose dans notre existence le
saccharose c'est vraiment un élément
longtemps pourrait se passer par contre
tous les autres sucres contenus dans les
miels c'est vraiment indispensable à
notre bien-être on considère la propolis
comme étant la l'antibiotique de la
ruche alors qu'est ce que la propolis et
bien c'est un produit que là bas il va
chercher sur les bourgeons de certains
arbres et elles vont en enduire
l'intérieur des ruches c'est en elles
rendent la ruche excessivement propre à
tel point que plus sur la fin de saison
sur le mois de septembre octobre eh bien
vous avez des rongeurs qui réussissent à
rentrer dans les ruches il apiculteurs
n'a pas été suffisamment précaution une
précautionneux les abeilles vont par
moments réussir à tuer cet individu mais
jamais n'arrivons à sortir le cadre à un
mot
musaraignes et bien le vent beau mais
c'est le cadavre avec de la propolis
aujourd'hui on commence à comprendre les
vertus du venin d'abeille sur notamment
la sclérose en plaques on les inspire
les études sont en cours après faut pas
demander plus à des spécialistes
et la cire clairement et bien pendant
des centaines d'années on s'est éclairé
avec la cia et je reviens si sur ces
animations
nous avons déjà parlé les happy days où
nous faisons fabriquer des bougies aux
enfants mais aussi aux grandes personnes
justement pour avoir cette
sensibilisation sur le rôle important de
la sir à un moment donné notre existence
d'êtres humains les produits de la ruche
qui sont d'une richesse exemplaire
j'oubliais le pôle m la diversité des
pollens la diversité des pollens
participent totalement on a parlé de la
diversité de l'alimentation de la ruche
clairement sur de la monoculture et bien
nos ruches vont avoir abandonné un souci
sanitaire
parce que l'abeille et comme nous l a
besoin de différentes protéines donc la
protéine de la ruche et bien sont les
pollens
si elle a passé de diversité ça
fonctionnera mal sedif sa diversité
aujourd'hui la trouvons ville je suis
heureusement malheureusement après je
sais pas comment on peut se placer mais
c'est là où vraiment on peut se rendre
compte également que
environ il ya de la biodiversité c'est
un exemple concret c'est un exemple tout
simple d'installation de ruches en ville
les régions très bien parce que il ya ce
facteur les clients comprennent alors
depuis 1995 30% des colonies
disparaissent chaque année en dix ans
quinze mille apiculteurs ont cessé leur
activité donc avec la disparition des
abeilles c'est des emplois qui
s'éteignent aussi vous entends capitule
terre ces difficultés là vous voulez
ressentais oui
de plus en plus fréquemment en sortie
d'hiver et bien les mortalité augmente
tadic ont considéré par le passé que 5%
mortalité en sortie d'hiver on était
dans le raisonnable on est passé à dix
suite on est passé à 15 aujourd'hui moi
je suis à 35 donc là on est un peu face
à un mur et c'est surtout une remise en
cause permanente et bien déjà de nos
pratiques apicoles on se pose des tas de
questions est ce que c'est moi ensuite
je veux que vous rencontrez les
apiculteurs professionnels où ils sont
dans les mêmes proportions c'est l'ordre
de grandeur c'est 30 35 40 %
donc voilà donc quand on ouvre les
ruches au printemps
on a toujours un petit peu la boule au
ventre on dit donc qu'est ce qu'on va
trouver est aujourd'hui le premier
travail de l'apiculteur c'est
effectivement un droit qu'on s'y était
aussi les 300000 colonies qu'on perd
chaque année puisque 30% ces trois cent
mille colonies à peu près 300 350 me
donc clairement le nombre de ruches ne
diminue pas le nombre d'apiculteurs ne
diminue pas parce qu'il ya un engouement
certain
par rapport à la bei à l'apiculture ont
de plus en plus de personnes quand il m
à l'api taylor
donc on est obligé chaque année de
reconstituer le cheptel ça ça impacte la
production et on est toujours
aujourd'hui obligés de constituer un
cheptel nécessaire et suffisant pour
essayer de devancer les éventuelles
pertes de la saison hivernale suivante
voilà à peu près où en est on
aujourd'hui dans le schéma de
l'apiculture
moi j'ai démarré la piqûre il ya une
quinzaine d'années on va dire je me
posais je me posais pas trop la question
c'est à dire que la saison se dérouler à
peu près normalement pour après avec les
aléas climatiques oui mais qui était pas
aussi marquée aussi que maintenant
parlons aussi de la production indienne
on a perdu 60 / 3 on a perdu 75% de la
production de miel en vingt ans
ça respon à l'arrivée sur le marché des
néonicotinoïdes voilà et vous fait ma
transition comme on vient de le dire
merci les abeilles sont effectivement
victime de plusieurs menaces il ya les
pesticides il ya aussi les parasites on
va essayer de comprendre un petit peu
toutes ces menaces on réécoute un
excellent documentaire le commerce
mondial dessin est à l'origine de
l'arrivée d'un parasites
le varroa destructor
mesurant environ 1 mm le varroa se
propage dans les cellules du couvain là
où se développent les larves
les individus sortons du couvain
subissent des malformations
les autres sont affaiblis et meurt
rapidement
il peut décimer une ruche en seulement
deux à trois ans
aucune variété d'abeilles n'échappe aux
attaques de ce parasite
alors le varroa voilà ce parasite
on a l'impression que la seule riposte
contre
ce varois c'est la riposte chimiques
c'est le cas ou pas
je me répandre je vais essayer d'y
répondre parce que oui actuellement oui
on n'a pas beaucoup d'alternatives pour
essayer de maîtriser varois dans les
ruches dont clairement on est on met de
la chemise en europe il ya des
traitements alternatifs mais qui sont
beaucoup moins efficaces
et qui oblige surtout à des contrôles
beaucoup plus rigoureux et très souvent
à des traitements complémentaires divers
donc ça c'est le premier point comment
il est arrivé en europe selon mehr ce
mondial commerce mondial il est arrivé
début des années 80 en france et c'est
pour ça que quand aujourd'hui on oublie
varois est responsable de la disparition
des colonies il y participe mais de 80
jusqu'au début des années 90 un milieu
des années quatre-vingt quinze varois
étaient déjà présents dans nos colonies
et il n'y avait pas plus que ça de
termes de colonies c'est à dire que à
une époque où l'apiculture le monde de
l'apiculture pardonnez moi l'expression
mais bricoler entre guillemets par
rapport à varois et bien l'apiculteur
sont certes encore pas trop mal et puis
au milieu des années 90 sont arrivés les
néonicotinoïdes
c'est une famille de pesticides
alors depuis leur arrivée la mortalité
des abeilles a augmenté de 50 à 80% dans
certaines régions contre 5% auparavant
qu'est ce que c'est ces pesticides axel
des courtilles en fait c'est une
nouvelle famille d'insecticides qui ont
la particularité d'être véhiculé dans la
plante par la sève donc les agriculteurs
les utilise en traitant les semences
donc ils traitent les graines il sème
les graines et puis le produit sont
retrouve donc dans la sève et le sceau
du coup se retrouver dans les fleurs qui
sont visitées par les par les butineuses
voilà donc des risques d'intoxication
donc mon ya plus de il n'y a plus trop
de débats on a c'est vrai qu'on a vécu
un débat en disant 15 ans est ce que ces
insecticides à avait un impact sur les
abeilles bon maintenant c'est prouvé
scientifiquement il ya bien un impact
il n'y a pas de doute voilà et je pense
qu'il faut sortir aussi du débat de est
ce que c'est la première cause est ce
que c'est la seconde cause est ce que
c'est la troisième cause il ya un impact
on le sait c'est pas pour ça à dire ça
c'est pas ce n'est pas défaussés varois
varois est un fléau qui touche toutes
les colonies quand j'entends dans le
reportage qu'il ya 15% des apiculteurs
en ville qui ne traiterait pas varois il
ya quand même un problème cdac
apiculteurs là il faut qu'ils maîtrisent
varois aussi c'est quand même une des
premières causes de mortalité hivernale
donc voilà donc on n'est plus dans diva
là par les varois s'est défaussé les
nicotine aux idées et les versements on
est face à des différents stress
d'unification de la gratification de
deux facteurs
les insecticides vont réduire les
défenses naturelles des abeilles varois
rv peut faire de même et donc varois
suivi d'un insecticide mais voilà c'est
la catastrophe et inversement c'est la
catastrophe aussi est il menacé sur ses
interactions de stress que nous on
travaille en tout cas dans le domaine de
la recherche et puis le problème de ces
insecticides aussi bruno parmentier 6
que en fait ils sont solubles dans l'eau
donc ils tombent dans les sols oui c'est
d'ailleurs une des unes de leurs
propriétés d'être sur la graine et de
protéger la graine contre les animaux
qu'ils mangent de la graine à
l'intérieur du sol donc d'un côté
c'était une idée qui avait l'air génial
coin parce que on a vu dans le film les
épandages aériens jeu a priori c'est
quand même beaucoup mieux de mettre de
l'insecticide uniquement droit sur la
graine que dépendent des insectes chine
mais c'est ça me fait ça me fait penser
au ddt
l'inventeur du ddt il est le prix nobel
de la paix est en lui et i due
probablement à des hommes qui a sauvé le
plus de vies dans le monde il a sauvé
des dizaines de millions de vies et puis
maintenant c'est bien ce que les pères
excusez moi mais c'est une belle vache
rit qui restent dans les x des défauts
que qui est permanent et qui est
totalement interdit donc il faut se
méfier de cette apparente modernité
c'était une bonne idée ben finalement
elle est pas si bonne que ça repenser or
donc il faut absolument protéger nos
cultures on peut pas non plus réduire la
production de céréales de légumineuses
etc on a besoin de manger la même besoin
d'augmenter de 70 % encore la production
agricole mondiale dans les 5 ans acquise
mais il faut aussi finalement les dégâts
collatéraux deviennent pires que le
sujet ben faut avoir la simplicité et la
modestie de faire un pas en arrière les
avancées gorée on va essayer autre chose
laurence abeilles ces pesticides dont
qui sont extrêmement nuisible pour
l'environnement pour les insectes et
notre santé à nous notre santé d'impact
et de la même façon il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on y échappe finalement on ne
fait partie de l'écosystème et donc on
consomme des aliments qui sont eux-mêmes
évidemment impacté par par ces
pesticides il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
l'urgence c'est de les interdire on
parle toujours de délai on dit en telle
année en telle année en telle année dans
la loi biodiversité et un amendement qui
est passé qui dit on interdit les
pesticides nous dit cottineau id dès
janvier 2016 c'était contre l'avis du
gouvernement mais avec l'avis favorable
des députés présents et j'espère que
cette ce dispositif va se maintenir
parce que vraiment il ya une urgence et
ça serait aussi une grande victoire pour
pour dire que on a n'a pas besoin qu'on
nous a fait croire pendant des années
que c'était des produits absolument
indispensable or c'est pas vrai et que
par ailleurs il ya de tout un tas de de
gens très compétents en agriculture qui
ont démontré depuis maintenant longtemps
qu'on a des des moyens de produire une
agriculture afin de produire de
l'agriculture de façon saine en europe
sans produits chimiques mais évidemment
ça va tout à fait à l'encontre des
intérêts d ailleurs fait ce que ça veut
dire qu'effectivement en france contre
l'avis du gouvernement l'assemblée
nationale avait voté l'interdiction à
compter de janvier 2005 de 2016 parlons
de ces produits et puis le sénat a
rejeté le texte qu est-ce qui se basait
non le sénat en fait n'a pas encore été
consulté sur le texte de loi sur la
biodiversité il va ça va arriver début
juillet mais que voilà en fait c'est un
sujet qui nous occupe on va dire depuis
pas mal d'années donc et les groupes
écologistes du sénat avec joël labbé de
l'assemblée nationale avec moi et
d'autres sont sur ces affaires de
pesticides et en particulier des
néonicotinoïdes
pour essayer absolument de les interdire
aussi bien la vente afin que les
particuliers puissent pas l'utilisation
de produits je pense au fameux roundup
ça c'est pas dans les néonicotinoïdes
mais bref qu'on arrête cette chimie za
sion si je puis dire de l'agriculture
aussi bien en milieu urbain dans tout ce
qui est jardins publics et autres que en
milieu rural où ces 100 local plus
important pour que enfin on arrive à
avoir des terres qu'ils soient sauvés de
la mort parce que ces terres elles ont
elles n'ont plus de vers de terre elles
sont on parle l'impact sur la santé
humaine mais c'est toute la flore et la
faune qui est impactée sur ces
territoires là est donc là l'assemblée
nationale a voté cet amendement en
première lecture le sénat va à deux pas
va donc examiner le texte en première
lecture également ça c'est au début du
mois de juillet le texte doit ensuite
revenir à l'assemblée nationale et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une mobilisation en ce
moment d'un certain nombre de
parlementaires tous bords confondus et
d'associations pour se veut vraiment
dire on doit maintenir absolument cet
amendement dans le texte et le texte de
la loi sur la biodiversité doit
prononcer cette interdiction le plus
rapidement possible en janvier 2005
c'est encourageant avec mon co
réalisateurs ont quadrillé urbain on
organise souvent nous invite à projeter
le film comme ça dans des mairies dans
des associations et on s'est toujours
rendu compte que les gens étaient avait
un engouement voulait arrêter avec les
pesticides voulait arrêter avec les
néonicotinoïdes ont fait confiance avec
à vous les politiques pour que les
décisions soient prises mais tous les
apiculteurs qu'on a rencontrés nous a
dit il ya ce problème des
néonicotinoïdes ya le problème du varois
mais le varois certain julien perrin qui
est dans le film essaye de développer
des veras d'abeilles qui soit résistante
elle même pour se défendre aux varois il
ya une dernière cause qui est énorme et
je pense que dominique je serais
d'accord c'est les variations
climatiques il ya des gros problèmes les
abeilles ont du mal à s'adapter à des
variations de température on commence un
jour le matin il fait 10 degrés on va se
retrouver le lendemain à la même heure à
25 degrés et ça c'est un gros problème
de fond là comme 21 va l'aborder à la
fin de l'année et ça aussi ça va il faut
faire des choses sur sur le climat
excellent des courtiers réagissent oui
sur les décisions politiques dont 16 15
ans que je travaille sur l'impact des
néonicotinoïdes donc notamment aux
travaux qui publiait en 2012 ont abouti
au retrait à l'interdiction de crise
heures sur sur colza on est toujours
content que nos travaux de recherches
servent à alimenter des décisions
politiques maintenant moi j'ai une
inquiétude c'est que
même si ces décisions vont dans le bon
sens il faudrait pas considérer que les
décisions vont sauver automatiquement la
bei que les politiques on y voit là on
vous a donné ça maintenant on a réglé le
problème voilà le il y aura encore des
problèmes donc ça va dans le bon sens
mais si on ne lutte pas contre varois
s'ils ont dû si on met pas les
ressources alimentaires dans l'est dans
les milieux si on n'a pas une génétique
appropriée à à l'environnement et à
l'apiculture que l'on veut on aura
encore des problèmes donc il faudrait
pas que ce soient les décisions qui ce
qui simpliste en disant voilà l'acte il
est fort et les politiques on a interdit
les stigmates on veut plus entendre
parler de l'abeille vont augmenter
c'est un changement total de
l'agriculture qu'on est en train de le
penser que l'agriculture moderne comme
elle est en france à une des inquiétudes
sur les plus modernes au monde mais
l'une des plus menacées parce que en
fait elle dépend de l'accès régulier à
des ressources non renouvelables
toujours plus de pétrole toujours plus
de chimie toujours plus de dents great
etc etc la réalité du 21e siècle c'est
la planète se réchauffe et les
ressources s'épuisent et donc ce système
à base de tracteurs d'engrais et de
pesticides il est vraiment menacée il
est menacé d'un côté parce que notre
santé la santé des abeilles etc mais il
est aussi menacée par l'épuisement des
ressources et par le réchauffement de la
planète est donc maintenant il va
falloir intensifier les processus
écologiques comme avant d'intensifier
les processus chimiques et là d'un côté
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce qu'on est
nul en agriculture écologique oui c'est
une révolution maman depuis 50 ans ne
cherche que de l'agriculture chimique
donc quelque part on est au bout des
découvertes un peu de l'agriculture
chimique mais on est au tout début des
découvertes de l'agriculture écologique
exemple on avait beaucoup d d'image dans
votre film où on voit un champ avec 10
hectares d'une seule espèce d'une seule
variété mais imaginait le prédateur qui
arrive au bord du champ et ramène tous
ses copains tous car il faut beaucoup
plus de diversité dans la mêlée à la
cantine les agriculteurs e s qui sont
prêts à ce changement là parce que on le
voit si si les apiculteurs par exemple
sont clairement opposés aux pesticides
par les agriculteurs ils ont dans une
situation qui est plus délicate parce
qu'ils doivent protéger leurs cultures
et en même temps bien sûr qu'ils hantent
souci de l'environnement alors comment
on fait exactement on vit un paradoxe
actuellement parce qu'on l'a déjà cité
trois ou quatre fois le 153 milliards
d'euros c'est pas c'est pas rien c'est
ça veut dire que dans les revenus des
agriculteurs normalement la bei est
quelque part voilà or aujourd'hui quand
on travaille avec les agriculteurs et
nous on le fait en leur disant moment là
on va changer vos systèmes qui sont trop
drastiques pour l'abeille trop risqué
pour la bei et on va les modifier tout
de suite on nous rétorque mais vous
allez toucher à ma durabilité économique
vous allez toucher hammam et bénéfices
économiques donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
réinventer
le système c'est voilà les agriculteurs
on leur a donné des béquilles un peu un
qui sont et qui était sa chimie pendant
un certain temps et donc il faut il faut
avec eux alors il ya des solutions il ya
des solutions il ya quelques
agriculteurs qui qui qui teste des
choses mais on a encore c'est vrai
besoin de prouver à l'échelle de
l'agriculteur pas que des chiffres macro
économiques à l'échelle du continent à
l'échelle de l'agriculteur comme quoi
non seulement il va pas perdre il
pourrait gagner en ayant un système
favorable aux abeilles 2007 à vous lire
oui là on parle de l'agriculteur mais je
pense qu'il faudrait peut-être qu'on en
tient compte et c'est à dire
consommateurs l'agriculteur en fait est
ce qu'il n'est pas là pour produire ce
que le consommateur lui demande c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on est rentré dans
un espèce de système de caprice ou on
veut un peu tout n'importe quand
n'importe comment ça c'est le premier
point l'exemple on essaie que dans par
exemple dans le concours des prairies
fleuries où on a mis sur le même
territoire des familles où vous aviez
sur le même territoire des agriculteurs
qui cherchait comment valoriser leurs
produits et des apiculteurs qui le
cherchait simplement à vivre de leurs de
produits de la ruche et bien ces gens là
se sont rencontrés ils ont mené des
expériences simples c'est à dire que
notamment ce sont des zones plutôt des
zones de semis fin de moyenne montagne
ou plutôt que de faucher les les foins
trop tôt c'est à dire avant d'arriver à
floraison et de laisser les
pollinisateurs et bien faire leur
travail
et ensuite mais les abeilles vivent est
rentré ce qu'elle avait rentré au niveau
de la ruche eh bien ils se sont entendus
pour que une fois que l'efsf les fleurs
ont été butiner et bien des agriculteurs
ont fauché et bien qu'on s'a aujourd'hui
il est clair c'est que effectivement il
ya peut-être un peu moins de produits au
niveau de l'agriculteur mais il ya
surtout une valise valorisation du
produit fini c'est à dire que ça donne
des meilleurs goûts aux produits finis
presque aux vols et aux produits
laitiers au fromage ainsi de suite donc
est-ce que c'est pas une piste aussi
d'échanger de recherche que plutôt
s'engouffrer dans
l'agroalimentaire avec des coopératives
et n'en avait qu'un unis défendent bien
et en même temps on a des exigences de
de production est vraiment parmentier
comment comment on passe d'une
agriculture cliniquement pardon
chimiquement aussi écologiquement
intensive c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
parce que on nage dans l'inconnu parce
que on est d'abord heureux donne
énormément de décisions l'agriculteur
parce que l'agriculteur finalement il
s'était abonnée aux fax to mail web
aujourd'hui il pleut vas-y toi 150
grammes de poudre viol est bon et puis
ça marche ça marche il en vit donc qui
dit mais je veux que ça continue et puis
bah maintenant l'agriculteur de demain
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué c'est la
prise de fait c'est bain ou en sont mes
abeilles on s'en remet vers de terre
nous en sommes et hérissons sont les
chauves-souris ou ans en mai mais en
jouant son etc et comment je peux
quelque part intensifier toute cette vie
pour pouvoir vivre et par exemple un
dessine de ça c'est l'abandon du labour
en fait le labour pourtant c'était quand
même une chose extraordinaire un des
deux mamelles de la france s'est
terminée le labour quelque part ça
consiste déjà par exemple à n'utiliser
le soleil que six mois par an mais celui
qui commence à ne plus la bourrée et à
dire je veux mettre de la biodiversité
et je vais utiliser les rayons du soleil
366 comme très compliqué pour lui parce
que tous les autistes tu bosses pas ou
quoi un pays qu'est ce que c'est que
toute cette vermine or attendait ce
qu'on associe nous la propreté c'est la
mort
d'abord de la biodiversité c'est ce
qu'on voit actuellement sur le bord de
nos routes heureusement qu'on ne faut
plus que la moitié et on s'aperçoit que
on a besoin de vie sur le bord de nos
routes donc on a besoin de faire le
partage entre la sécurité routière et la
vie et les sons s'il vous plaît des
fleurs est ce que risque par exemple
parce que les etats unis se sont aussi
engagés clairement en tout cas barack
obama s'est exprimé sur la question il
va investir 80 millions pour les
abeilles transformer 2 8 millions
d'hectares de terrains publics en paiera
le jeu pour les pollinisateurs c'est une
solution ça ou ça suffira c'est super a
pas puis après on doit conclure moi j'ai
envie de parler d'effet d'annoncé
franchement là dessus parce que je pense
que c'est vraiment la transformation en
profondeur du modèle agricole qui peut
recréer rebelles de la biodiversité et
donc effectivement sauver les abeilles
qui sont les sentinelles de la
biodiversité donc c'est bien que
monsieur obama se préoccupe de cette
question là je crois pas beaucoup à ses
solutions et bien d'autres elles sont
mieux mais pas vraiment c'est un peu la
limite et c'est à dire que on va sur sur
des petits territoires forme de
territoire dire bah voilà là on va
mettre les abeilles vont être contentes
et on va continuer à tuer les sols et
eaux vives sur les pesticides est
absolument partout et on n'a pas parlé
vraiment de la santé des agriculteurs
mais ils sont les premières victimes ces
pulvérisations qu'ils font on le sait
maintenant et je pense qu'il ya de plus
en plus d'agriculteurs qui sont
volontaires pour changer ça passe par la
formation ça passe par la volonté
politique à son nombre de contraintes
qui doivent être donnés mais je pense
qu'après il ya une émulation qui se fera
tout naturellement et on va où devra
nécessairement arrêter cette agriculture
qui tue et qui polluent alors voilà ce
sera le mot de la fin on espère que tout
ça évoluera dans le bon sens merci à
tous d'être venus sur ce plateau la
semaine prochaine laurent bazin vous
proposera un documentaire sur des choix
je vous retrouve dans 15 jours nous
partirons en avignon un retour sur un
festival il y a un an menacés par la
percée du front national au municipal à
bientôt sur public sénat
comment